pavetta coming in nine and six of 443
era pavella looking to return to form
after a 5-2 loss at yankee stadium which
he tossed a season low and inning in
two-thirds he gave up four runs first
inning has been trouble for him when he
gets out of it quickly usually leads to
good stuff debra's will throw off
balance safe at first
kepler beat the wrap we'll send a
polanco 274 23 home runs and he missed
ball four good start to the inning
kepler walks to second polanco walks to
first for donaldson runners lead at
first and second here's the 3-2
he struck him out fastball to put him
away that was an excellent pitch
donaldson the strikeout victim so two
down one more he gets out of it
hard hit but he gets to zander quickly
and that will be out number three so
pavetta gets the next three after two
men reach to begin the inning maybe over
15th start has been better recently
better each time out the first pitch
strike is huge the fastball at the top
of the zone is big now kyle schwarber
and the o2 and down he goes in a high
fastball strike three swinging but two
men out quickly and here's comes xander
here comes pitch number nine
and that is strike three called on a
slider 85 outside corner so the ninth
pitch of the at-bat finally ends it so
savannah's got himself another inning
where he will throw a lot of pitches
under duress cave the batter with
runners at first and second
bounty ball at first shaw picks it low
throw and a nice play there by xander
bogarts to at least get one excellent
pick by xander right there so xander
picking up his first baseman they're on
the corners for simmons who's sending
just two 18s that tough year
and simmons softly into center field an
rbi single gordon coming in from third
and the twins again tonight take the
first lead and so the bases are jammed
from minnesota and for their top hitter
polanco he swings away and pops it up
coming on long run martinez and jd gets
there and the runner will hold it third
so pavetta gets polanco it's a huge out
but here's donaldson who struck out his
first time up
driven to center field
we do go all the way back to the track
leaps up and into the wall as he catches
it
he had another step to go he left his
fade and got it that looked like it
would hit some wall but he gets out of
the jam so they score one but leave them
loaded so deborah's on lead it off jd
martinez next
and martinez was susceptible to
jax's slider last night ober got him
there for a strikeout one down so now
vernugo will get the 1-1 pitch a fly boy
to right center field this one near the
track caught by kepler two outs and now
renfro three-two pitch and down he goes
chase to high fastball and over despite
the walk strikes out two more now four
strikeouts through two so one down and
here comes miguel cino for one tonight
[Music]
launched to left field very deep and
gone
miguel sano cleared the billboard in
deep left center field and it's a two
nothing twins lead 495
feet the longest home run of the year in
big league baseball but as sanel crossed
home plate he tugged on his twins jersey
and looked at somebody in the boston
dugout with the young kid in the miguel
cino bad so during batting practice
tonight miguel cino at a home run out to
right field and ceno's home run ball hit
him in the head miguel was able to find
out where he's seated for the actual
game as a thank you the kids said hey
he'll get a hit tonight and relayed that
to the usher and it got back to the
twins and miguel said okay how about i
hit a home run travis shaw to lead it
off in the bottom of the third red sox
trailing at two to nothing swinging a
miss and young goes shaw high fastball
plays well again for over his fifth
strikeout away in the red sox third for
vazquez hitting 255.
and there's a shot past the diving
simmons for a base in red sox have their
first hit finally vasquez to second two
down for schwarber
line that's going to get down and right
field vasquez heading into third up with
a kepler as he fires home and he'll
freeze the runner at third base and
schwarber with a base hit so give him 22
consecutive games aboard
kyle schwarber's base hit there
christian thought it was just one out
and he froze right there with the base
hit to right field
and he tried to get kyle's attention
while he was at third base to say my bad
flying into right field on the approach
here's kepler and that is all red sox
with a threat but strand two it's
simmons on now two down he's in scoring
position batter now is going to be
polanco
got a fast ball crack to right field
renfrow back and that ball is gone
polanco again
with his ninth home run of the month
doubling the twins lean it's four to
nothing right down the heart of the
plate flacco didn't miss it there's alex
verdugo
that's to the left back to the wall cave
hoping for a bounce and he'll get one
and it'll be gordon playing the carom
and
they will hold verdugo and they got him
at first
verdugo with a big turn
and his retreat
unsuccessful because gordon played the
carom
and threw quickly to second base and the
inning ends with another base running
mistake made by the red sox it'll be a
leadoff single shaw bats
came back with a better change up to get
a swinging strike three one down if he
can develop that as his third pitch
another way to get lefties out two gone
for
his glove with his right hand
and strikes out hernandez red sox have
an extra base hit for the first time
tonight vasquez trying to deliver the
red sox first run
up the middle and a base hit
here comes shaw roundy third
gordon's throw will be cut better red
sox get on the board at last there you
go
vasquez delivers
his second hit it is four to one three
straight hits red sox now challenging
first and second they'll bring on the
lefty for schwarber
[Music]
gordon back
with roon out number two front runner
will tag second runner will not because
the throw comes back to the middle of
the infield two away
but an rbi opportunity for beau guards
over two of the walk this evening strike
three call on the outside corner
a fastball in 93 and bogart strikes out
and strands a pair
so vert dugo is two for four that makes
him eight for his last 11. so renfro one
for three
strokes that one that's headed for the
wall high off the monster paduco taking
off hit it for third
big turn back to first goes renfro
trickles in here comes the runner
he will score on
that's what they need four to two
so it's renfro at second all back at
first with two down for vazquez good
night for christian at the plate and the
pitch a ground ball left side this is
glove by rise feet second base for the
force with polanco there in time to end
the inning the red sox score run on a
couple hits they strand two we go to the
ninth inning the new score twins four
red sox two alex coleman hasn't pitched
since he blew a save against the indians
he kicked a second base and he'll hold
there tying run coming to the plate and
kyle schwarber
swinging a drive
center field deep came turning around
it's gone
[Applause]
it is ty
what a spot for schwarber's first home
run as a member of the red sox we're
knotted at four
first ball swinging he hit a bomb over
the bleacher bar it's his 26th of the
year donaldson two strikeouts a warning
track fly ball to center and then the
double off the monster and left
a high fly right center field and deed
and donaldson goes deep over the bullpen
a two-run home run and the twins are
back in front it's six to four twins in
the tenth inning ref snyder at second
jeffers at first and cave his sixth twin
to bat in this tenth inning pitch is
swinging a fly ball into right center
field this one's deep this one's towards
the seats and that ball's gone
j cave a two out tenth inning three run
homer
right after the mountain visit and the
twins break it open and have a 9-4 lead
in the 10. a rally here first and third
with nobody out and i'll bring up
vasquez and the 3-2 pitch and swinging a
ground ball to third glove by rise
second for one polanco's return in time
double play
that is a double play ball renfro scores
a 9-5 game but that clears the bases and
now two outs here comes kiki hernandez
here's the 1-2 pitch swinging a high
deep drive down the left-field line
and that ball into the monster seat
she's gone
[ __ ] did that last night and he's
repeated it here tonight and the red sox
still have a heartbeat schwarber tied
the game with a two-run home run
a more conventional over-the-top
delivery oh boy
arise with the catch after he looked
away
and the twins end up winning in extra
innings two home runs in the 10th inning
providing the difference
you